[Music]
Innovation is essential because the
society that we're working with and
trying to protect from the ills of
public health problems is a society
that's changing very quickly and when a
society changes quickly we need to
innovate in response to
[Music]
that we were very interested in the
question of what is causing cancer it's
a very widespread concern people have
but moreover a given patient often wants
to know what caused their cancer and in
the past what people have been able to
say are things like oh well if you smoke
you're more likely to get cancer if you
have this genetic predisposition you're
more likely to get cancer but that's not
really an answer to the question of why
did I get cancer and on just recently
we've been able to answer that question
by doing tumor sequencing being able to
see the actual effects of what's causing
the mutations that led to that tumor and
then being able to quantify how those
mutations contribute to the tumor so
that we can actually ask the question if
someone has lung cancer What proportion
of your cancer was caused by smoking
What proportion was by age What
proportion was by viral infection these
sorts of things are things that in the
past we've never been able to tell
someone and it's the kind of innovation
that hopefully will be helpful in
improving Public Health by being able to
tell people why they're getting ill
and by expressing that uh information to
those who get ill and for having those
people pass that information on to those
they love so that they can better
understand what they can do to prevent
the same ills from affecting them in the
past we've always had to do sort of uh
one might call gumo epidemiology which
is like investigating all the possible
causes that might relate to the people's
cancer and sort of just figuring out
from no information whatsoever by being
in the area and exploring what sort of
carcinogens they may have encountered
why they're more likely to have come up
with a cancer but in this case we could
actually take those individuals who get
cancer and look at the tumor genome that
they have and better understand what
sorts of causes might be apparent just
from what kinds of mutations occur in
the tumor genome and from that that may
give us a direction and a faster route
towards understanding these hot spots
where individuals get cancer uh at
higher rates than places I think the
Yale School Public Health has a very
great appreciation of the complexity of
the society we live in and uh the fact
that the society that we live in is
changing very rapidly and so at the core
of its mission is the idea that we need
to develop the science that underlies
the policy decision- making and the
science progress that we need to make in
terms of uh innovating for Public
Health
[Music]